Ashley's with us in Indiana hey actually
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show oh my
goodness thank you so much Jay for
taking our call my honor how can I help
well I have I'm a longtime listener my
husband and I have been following your
program for about five years and we've
paid off about a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars worth of debt and
that's also we've also we have five kids
or we've had during that time and I've
heard people call in my husband also to
ask about the federal loan forgiveness
program and I I'm pretty confident I
know your feelings on that
but our situation is a little bit
different than other callers I've heard
my husband has documented he has
documentation that he has only two and a
half years left to qualify we have
everything paid off except his student
loan that we're trying to get forgiven
it has about a hundred and thirty five
thousand dollars left he's an attorney
our house has about a hundred and
sixty-five thousand dollars left and we
calculated we would be able to pay off
our home in two and a half years so the
timeline is about the same I'm wondering
his his and I plan right now is to
attack the mortgage on the house pay it
off in that time and then hopefully his
loan will be forgiven
[Music]
the other option we've talked about is
saving that huge chunk of money okay do
you understand that the Department of
Education has denied the request for
forgiveness
99% of the applications I do sir 99%
your husband really thinks he's in the
1% he absolutely does know and I think
that's a tree
as I listen to your show more I'm not
getting confidence in it at all anytime
the federal government screws something
up as bad as they have this program I
don't have any confidence in it at all
if you want to do it this way you're not
gonna go broke you're not gonna go
bankrupt it's not gonna be in the world
you are gonna face an amazing amount of
disappointment and you're gonna have to
continue to stick you're gonna have to
step up and knock the student loan out
just like you were going to knock your
mortgage out because all you're doing is
flipping these two amounts if you want
to go this way you can go this way but I
really you know I really want to set you
up so you're not so disappointed I want
to lower your expectations right if you
want to go do it go do it but don't go
do it like I know I've got this it's a
lock when 99% of people get turned down
there is no such thing as a lock right
so would it be better in that case to
save that huge chunk of money anyway in
the two and a half years now you could
do that too and apply and then when you
get turned down you could just pay it
off well my husband will be listening to
this because the reason I called no I
wanted him to hear it from you well I
mean there's there's a 1% possibility
that he's you know in that 1% and he's
an attorney he knows how to fill out
stuff you know and so he knows how the
law works but but I mean that's the
numbers it's it's actually less than 1%
of the applications for student loan
forgiveness to the Department of
Education have been accepted it's a 99
percent turn down ratio that's a pretty
that's not much of a plan you know right
if you got a 1% chance for success that
that it's not really encouraging so yeah
if you want just pile up the cash for
two and a half years that's fine and
then beyond that go ahead and start
paying on your mortgage that's probably
what I would do instead of paying off
the mortgage yeah let's just keep these
baby steps in order and you just pile
them up you got two and a half years
you're still in debt but the money
sitting there and then once you give up
and say gosh I'm not really in the 1%
they're not gonna forgive it then there
we go
right
just ride check pay it off thanks for
the call